I've never totally understood why trans
culture always has like more and more I
feel like it intersects with drag
culture which dry culture wasn't
necessarily transgender in and of itself
from my understanding of it I mean it's
interesting to me that you know women my
age women younger than me are really
interested in like the clean girl
aesthetic right minimal makeup and you
know they wear their hair natural and
stuff like that and like on the other
hand if you are transgender suddenly
you're wearing extremely high heels and
you have really long nails and you have
you know it's not all women don't wear
makeup and all trans people do or makeup
but it's just it seems like there is an
aesthetic nature that doesn't feel
genuine it feels like you have to
present this way to a firm that you are
this identity it's like the more the
more the trans person desires to be in
the public eye the more they tend to uh
be a caricature of what femininity is or
or uh you know more like uh the the
ideal of femininity